[Musique]
à l'issue d'un conseil restreint de
défense le premier ministre prend la
parole il n'y aura pas de troisième
confinement pour le moment ce soir nous
considérons au regard des chiffres des
derniers jours que nous pouvons encore
nous donner une chance de l'éviter
apéritif en plein air pour ce groupe
d'amis tous redoutaient d'être à nouveau
qu on finit on le fait tout le temps
l'événement on aurait fait le plein
puisque le confinement à l'oreille on
l'aurait fait est chez nous on nous
autorise à sortir à elle est bordée ils
sont comme ça mais là c'est parce qu'il
a dit hier le premier ministre il n'a
pas dit en autorise à sortir aller boire
des coups d'accord mais s'est ouvert
sous verre donc en fait on a le droit il
ya personne pour nous arrêter nous dire
que c'est pas bien pour les mesures qui
ont été prises hier ne vont pas suffire
à l'évidence un car on voit mal gré la
le garde le volvo c'est une certitude
elles ne vont pas suffire écoutez malgré
les couvre feux qu'on a pris le début du
mois de janvier on voit aujourd'hui un
mois après trois semaines avec quatre
semaines après qu'on continue d'avoir
des cas qui augmente et on peut dire
laurence qu'on a respecté un alcool
sanitaires extrêmement strict vraiment
ne sommes pas dans une salle de théâtre
et on pense évidemment aux salles
fermées mais on est dans un studio de
télévision toutes les règles ont été
respectées par tout le monde des gens
étaient testés nous sommes séparés par
des rails à tous nous sommes nous-mêmes
passé au gel hydroalcoolique
c'est aberrant il faut comme moi mettre
un masque comme tout le monde de faire
attention et je crois que ça c'est utile
mais le récent ça sert à rien du tout en
ce moment la télé consomment beaucoup
rire des gens qu un avis sur tout y
compris quand ils savent pas pourquoi
mais c'est bon d'ailleurs chacun des
recettes plutôt vers ans ou raul chevaux
à a
tu vois on est obligé d'avoir des amis
vous êtes député des bouches-du-rhône à
marseille j'imagine que vous l'avez
rencontré khalid je lui dois jouer
téléphoner un outil extrêmement aimable
très détendu il ya une chose qui la fait
qui m'a beaucoup surpris l'as dit du mal
de personnes
et de veiller
en fait tu sais
qualité
[Musique]
si on se compare aux pays de l'union
européenne les plus importants en terme
de population tels que l'espagne
l'italie ou l'allemagne
eh bien on se rend compte qu'on est
largement derrière du simple au double
même avec l'allemagne si on prend
maintenant l'ensemble des pays lieu et
qu'on regarde le nombre de vaccinés pour
100 habitants
eh bien la france arrive péniblement à
l'éclair à la 22e place sur 27 s'est pas
capables d'acheminer des doses de la
guerre peut vous interromps 2030 je vous
[ __ ] pourquoi que d'une vieille 13
stratégie trotskiste de dire qu'on n'est
pas touché mais était trop ce qui sera
fait de dire des bêtises va vraiment
savoir le niveau exceptionnel non mais
attendez ce nom me vend deux fois contre
productif
franchement
[Rires]
j'imaginais qu on pourrait juste avant
le printemps le printemps c'est le 21
mars donc on a un samedi juste avant le
samedi en question le 20 mars
on pourrait faire une fête de la liberté
juste avant le printemps le fait des
libertés d'abord pour dire à monsieur
macron qu'on a repéré ces lois
liberticides
mais on ferait quelque chose qui serait
pas comme d'habitude bien sûr honorer
nos pancartes et rennes et surtout
offrait une énorme fête qui marcherait
l'accord ses bases
j'ai la lune bon 6e mais non mais c'est
pas gentil si bien géré on a perdu qu
ils s'étaient promis de se dire oui
quoi qu'il arrive les i care 31 ans et
simone o'brian 36 ans n'aurait jamais
imaginé se marier sur un lit d'hôpital
en réanimation
[Musique]
enfant à moulins d'espoir
juste après s'être dit je le veux
saimone o'brian émis sous respirateur
leur premier baiser il ne les changerons
que quelques jours plus tard j'avais
tellement envie de revoir l'isi donc
j'ai tout fait je me suis battue battu
pour reprendre mon souffle battu pour
revenir et j'ai réussi
oui vous m'expliquer comment à travers
ses chansons
vous pouvez déclencher des envies
sexuelles et des tonnerres d'orgueil
chez les femmes par le monde orthodoxe
je tiens à le relever c'est que en fait
ils ont le choix
ah ben moi je lui dédie leur vie à dieu
d'ailleurs il y en a trois qui ont dédié
leur vie à dieu les deux autres ils vont
se marier 405 à venir avec la bid prête
quand même avec quoi avec
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est la quéquette recherche c'est la
crécq est la recherche et nom d'animal
donnes ton à une femme de plus de 40 ans
qui séduit des hommes plus jeunes un
accroc un enfant
la pandémie a montré l'excellente santé
de la langue française
on a créé en confinement déconfinement
rdée confinement re des consignes et à
6,8 sont des mots bien formés bien
attesté utile ce sont les meilleurs
candidats au dictionnaire à chicago à et
aux eaux turquoises jeudi le calme
c'est ça le sénateur bernie sanders en
fait ex-candidat à la présidentielle
bien qu'on ait tout fait dans ces moules
si j'ai dit mot des moules que ce soit
clair si à part un montage qui ai fait
ma demande de bernie sanders dans des
moules activités quoi aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
il est le seul absolument incroyable
ça
car trois que
[Musique]